pl annonce le transfert des activités de
ces centres vers une nouvelle usine
automatisé à cornwall en ontario
olivier deschamps comment l'aube là
explique sa décision l'aube lundi que
ces deux entrepôts gérald eux sont
devenus désuets alors c'est pour cette
raison-là que des activités seront
transférées dans un nouveau centre de
distribution ultramoderne entièrement
automatisée qui se trouve à cornwall en
ontario alors à la valse et 545
personnes qui perdent leur emploi à
ottawa ces 230 l'annoncé a été faite
aujourd'hui tout juste au retour du
congé des fêtes
alors certains travailleurs l'ont appuyé
sont sous le choc présentement parce
qu'ils perdent car même de bons emplois
payés de 20 à 30 $ l'heure on va écouter
la réaction des travailleurs suivis des
explications de provigo celle en vrai
pour peut-être pas pour moi mais je suis
senti si lent mais pour tout mitcham
gens déjà enfin des maisons des dettes
sont jeunes ce sont 50 un seul appareil
je trouve pas anormal genre tu nous
remplacera d'airbourne lozère on
travaille fort depuis tant d'années pour
se faire remplacer finama pas des
machines
françois s'en viennent même pas tous
loin d'aider notre bouclier bouthillier
le pays ce qu'ils sont et avait atteint
ont atteint à toute fin pratique leur
cycle de vie utile et il fallait prendre
des mesures parce qu'ils ne présentaient
pas de potentiel pour les rénover et
vous savez que le commerce de détail
c'est très très compétitif
provigo et le syndicat pendant ce temps
là veulent aider les travailleurs
peut-être à se trouver de nouveaux
emplois
oui le syndicat dit qu'il va tenter dans
un premier temps de négocier les primes
de départ n'est plus avantageuse
possible pour les employés qui sont
touchés ici à laval provigo va tenter de
trouver effectivement des nouveaux
emplois aux gens qui vont perdre leur
emploi d'ici 2021 et le ministre du
travail jean boulet lui se dit également
prêt à épauler les travailleurs il s'est
une nouvelle qui me déçoit pour
l'économie du québec c'est 550 emplois
me dit en jappant aussi évidemment aux
familles aux travailleurs affectés mais
sans chic on est des gens nous en action
un des conseillers en entreprise de mon
ministère est entré en communication
avec les personnes de l'eau blanc et on
va faire un suivi adéquat pour que le
comité des douars placement soit
structuré le plus rapidement possible
alors ce qui pourrait peut-être un peu
aider ces travailleurs dans leur malheur
selon syndicat gérald c'est la rareté de
la main-d'oeuvre actuellement et de
nombreux employeurs qui sont à la
recherche d'employés
absolument ollier bachand merci au
revoir au revoir